breaking news overnight a reporter for
the al jazeera network was shot and
killed while covering an israeli raid in
the west bank mts taeyab is tracking the
latest developments for us from london
mts it's always sad when a journalist
dies in the field reportedly this
journalist was wearing one of those
familiar blue flak jackets that said
press clearly good morning what else do
we know
tony good morning well what we do know
is shireen abu aklas set out early this
morning to cover an israeli raid in the
town of janine now a warning here some
of the images are distressing but she
can be seen wearing a helmet and body
armor that was clearly marked as press
when she was shot the journalist next to
her here said they were targeted by
israeli forces now abu al-aqla's
employer al jazeera said the veteran
reporter was and i'm quoting here
assassinated in cold blood by israeli
forces israel's prime minister called
the death unfortunate and blamed it on
palestinians claiming they were quote
firing indiscriminately a second
journalist was shot in the back but
survived now the u.s ambassador to
israel is now calling for a thorough
investigation there have been near daily
raids in the west bank amid a series of
deadly attacks inside israel with janine
a main flashpoint now on a purely
personal note i knew shereen we used to
work together in jerusalem and she was a
kind and generous colleague always
looking to give voice to those who were
so rarely heard from but more than
anything she was a pioneer a household
name across the arab world shireen
started her career in the 1990s when
there were few arab women reporting on
issues that affected their communities
she truly inspired a generation of other
arab women to do the same and will be
greatly missed gail
oh i'm so sorry that you knew her and so
sorry for your loss mts it was just
another painful reminder about how
dangerous this job can be thank you so
much